it helps kill bacteria and viruses and
it can even be set on fire this is hand
sanitizer this gooey substance is
normally meant for the hands but what if
we covered our bodies in it
specifically by jumping into a pool full
of hand sanitizer
what would submerging yourself in hand
sanitizer feel like could you swallow
some of it and is this the best way to
kill deadly diseases this is what if and
here's what would happen if you jumped
into a pool full of hand sanitizer hand
sanitizer is made up of a huge list of
chemicals from things that make it a gel
to the moisturizers and lubricants but
its main ingredient is ethanol this is
what kills the germs on your hands in
order to be truly effective it should
have over 60 percent ethanol so to kill
all the deadly viruses on our bodies
let's use something stronger a 95
percent concentration of ethanol okay
now that we've chosen our hand sanitizer
what happens if we jump into a pool full
of it as soon as you jump in any cuts or
open wounds you might have would
immediately begin to sting have you ever
had a hangnail on your finger and used
hand sanitizer
yeah remember how much that hurt now
imagine the alcohol and other chemicals
attacking every cut or scratch you might
have on your body no if you don't have
too many of those you'll be able to swim
around in our field full of hand
sanitizer but swimming in something like
this would be more like swimming in
jelly than in water this gel substance
would be a gloppy thick mess to swim
through and if you dunked your head into
it it would fill your ears nose and any
other crevice it can make its way into
and while you're under there don't cry
opening your eyes if you do you'll
immediately feel severe pain from the
hand sanitizer and if we don't wash it
out immediately you could go blind yeah
alcohol is not good for the eyes and
let's hope you don't swallow any of this
stuff if you did it would taste pretty
disgusting like an incredibly harsh
alcohol with a strong chemical taste and
if you drink enough of it you would be
extremely intoxicated that's because a
240 milliliter bottle of hand sanitizer
contains the same amount of alcohol as
about five shots of hard liquor
luckily swallowing it is avoidable what
isn't is the damage these chemicals
would be doing to your skin while you
were in there if you were in hand
sanitizer long enough it could filter
through your skin and get into your
bloodstream the reason why we can put
hand sanitizer on our hands is that they
have tougher skin than other parts of
our body the skin on places like our
faces and butts is pretty weak and soft
so if your entire body was marinating
and hand sanitizer it could lead to
alcohol poisoning and we know that hand
sanitizers purpose is to kill bacteria
but it gets rid of both the bad and good
germs having small doses on your hands
is okay but spreading it all over your
body would kill a lot of the good
bacteria you have on your skin this
could make you very sick or even kill
you and hopefully you won't have any
smokers standing nearby because if they
happen to drop a match or a lighter into
the pool the hand sanitizer would
instantly burst into flames and quickly
kill you
but if you managed to survive all of
this and made it out of the pool you'd
need to shower immediately and after
that your skin would begin to feel tight
to dry it would start to crack and bleed
and
incredibly painful let's hope you have
another pool of skin lotion to jump into
so it's pretty clear that hand sanitizer
is only good in small doses and only on
our hands besides if you really want to
kill bacteria just wash your hands trust
me
it's a lot safer cheaper and healthier
and because washing your hands is so
good for you well why don't we try
something really dumb and not wash them
for an entire year yeah you know that's
a story for another whatever
[Music]